(audience applauding)
Thank you so much for having me, this was so much fun.
Winnie, thank you so much for coming here.
Really and truly it's been like,
not just inspirational talking to you,
but just fun and cool.
And you're an awesome person and I'm crazy for you.
I already was crazy for you,
but now I'm crazy, crazy, crazy!
And I, I can't wait-
Well we're equally crazy
for each other then.
I'm obsessed with this, the vibe, the vibe.
Okay, perfect, I'm there.
And also, I would love to talk about your skincare line
that you're developing.
So it's in the works right now.
It's something that I've been working on for years.
An idea I had years ago.
I don't know how much I can say about it,
but look out for it in a year.
It's all about sexiness and about protection. (laughs)
I must say that I pretty much would buy
anything you are selling.
Whether it's a product-
Don't worry.
I'm gonna send it to you.
I want you to try it first.
I am-
I need your feedback.
I, you know, I'm a beauty junkie.
I am obsessed with products.
Exactly.
I need your feedback.
I need to know if it's worth it.
I need to know if it's the new hot thing for next year.
I gotta tell you, if you've got a hand in it,
I bet it's gonna be amazing,
because everything you say and do is.
And I need to like throw down with you, let's party.
And like, let's do this.
Winnie, you have beyond exceeded.
I would really-
You don't know.
You saying this to me, right now is gonna make me cry.
I swear, this is too much for me. I can't. (laughs)
I love you.
Thank you.
And I would love to throw down with you and party.
Winnie, here, walk forward
and we can try and hug each other.
Uh, I go to you.
Ah!
(both laughing)
Walking right through me.
All right
we'll go back to back.
Back to back.
Yeah.
(audience applauding)
Oh yeah.
I'll stand right here.
Muah, muah, muah, muah, muah!
(Winnie laughing)
Maybe we can like dance our way
into commercial.
Do a little vibing?
Yes, exactly.
(upbeat music)
Oh, Winnie, I love hanging out with you.
Thank you so much for coming on the show.
Oh my God.
I mean, look at her.
Though let me get my little Caribbean in there.
Oh my God, yes!
Oh no, I'll, oh yeah!
(audience applauding)
Oh my God.
Ah, ah, ah!
(Winnie laughing)
We'll go to break on that note.
Thank you, Winnie.
(audience applauding)
Oh my God!
(upbeat music)